the al-hadidi children were buried this
saturday
abdul rahman and osama
four brothers who died with their mother
maha on the heaviest night of bombing
the people of gaza have ever experienced
they had been at their uncle's house to
celebrate eid the end of ramadan
when the airstrike came their father
wasn't with them
he survived
foreign
but out of this some good news the
al-hadidis had a fifth boy
omar it is a wonder the baby survived
but he did and he's now recovering in
hospital
in the middle of an enclave in pieces
the israeli bombardment has continued
day and night
yet militants continue to fire their
rockets north out of gaza
unguided and with a range that's jolted
the israeli psyche
a world away but just 40 miles at a tel
aviv beach bar
behind the music the sound of the air
raid siren
people rush to the shelters
the rocket hit a few miles away on this
street in the suburb of ramadan
one man in his 50s was killed by
shrapnel cars were destroyed
and the buildings around damaged among
the eyewitnesses
local resident jaffa seller
i am a shock i'm a shock
i i can't believe what happened in
israel
i want peace only peace only peace
arabs and israel don't war never war
never never never
[Music]
this is tragic this is frightening but
what's happening in gaza
is so much more frightening for the
civilians there the women the children
the hospitals that are next to buildings
that are being hit the schools that are
right next to buildings that are being
hit
the proportionality i think that's what
people are interested in
i don't know how frighteningly
frightening it is in gaza i know that
it's very frightening
to be a civilian in israel who knows
that they are the target
our civilians know that they are the
target for hamas
civilians in gaza they may be affected
which
is regrettable and we try to minimize
those casualties
if there was any sense just a few hours
ago that perhaps a truce or a ceasefire
was possible well that is gone now with
this
striking in the heart of a tel aviv
suburb
back in gaza just 40 miles to the south
the residents of this building received
a call from the israelis
it was a target and they had an hour to
leave
it's home for media organizations al
jazeera and the associated press
they left and it was taken down
the israelis say hamas militants also
used the building as its military
intelligence office
no one was killed but with media
equipment destroyed
it's harder now to get stories and
pictures out of here
not far from the building destroyed omar
al-hadidi will continue to be cared for
in hospital
he is some hope in a place where it's
hard to find
mark stone sky news in israel